بعد قرار الرئيس الاوكراني
الى النهايه وصلت تعزيزات كبيره الى
المدينه مما ينذر باحتدام المعارك في
الايام المقبله المدينه المحاصره من ثلاث
جهات لم يعد يربطها بمناطق النفوذ
الاوكراني الا طريق واحد عبر بلده
تشاسوفيا وبسبب ارتفاع درجات الحراره
تحول هو الاخر الى تحد بحد ذاته خبر سيء
اخر للاوكرانيين باجنر باتت تسيطر على شرق
المدينه والمعارك انتقلت الى وسط المدينه
وعبرها تسعى فاجنر الى قطع طريق
من الشمال مهمه فاجنر لن تكن سهله لن تكون
سهله المعارك انتقلت الى محيط مصنع ازيوم
للصلب وهو نسخه مصغره عن مصنع ازوف في
ماريوبول حسن منيع وبطوابق عديده تحت
الارض قوات فيرنر تسعى لتجنب مصنع ازوم
والهدف هو محاصره المدينه بقطع الامدادات
عنها ويصبح ذلك تكرار سنيوريو ماريوبول
مساله وقت فقط
تقع مدينه باخبوت على نهر باخ بوتفكار
شمالي مقاطعه دونيسك شرق اوكرانيا تبعد
نحو 50080 كيلومترا عن العاصمه كيف يعود
تاسيسها الى عام
1571 بان حكم قيصر روسيا ايفانا رهيب تبلغ
مساحتها نحو واحد واربعين كيلو متر مربعا
اما سكانها فقد بلغ عددهم نحو 71 وفقا
لاخر احصائيه قبل الهجوم الروسي فيما فر
نحو 90% منهم بعد الحرب بحسب سلطات
المقاطعه تركيبتها السكانيه متنوعه بين
الاوكرانيين وذوي الاصول الروسيه كما توجد
فيها اقليه اخرى
كالبيلاروسيين والارمن وتعد باخموت احدى
اكبر مراكز صناعات الالات الثقيله في
اوكرانيا كما تعتمد بشكل اساسي على
استخراج الملح الصخري حيث تقع مناجم الملح
في مدينه
سوليدار الواقعه على بعد نحو عشره
كيلومترات والتي احكمت القوات الروسيه
قبضتها عليها مؤخرا